House Republicans have introduced the
bill to terminate the Department of
Education now this is part of their
argument of their positioning that
anybody directing education in the
United States particularly at the
federal level is doing it in a woke way
where children are being indoctrinated
the reality is so many of these states
and in particular red States desperately
need help to actually get students ready
to go into the real world with knowledge
with the ability to think critically Etc
and the states are failing this is the
opposite of what should be done the
Department of Education should actually
be better funded Republicans want to get
rid of it they are backwards on this
along with so many other issues